[Musica]
Ciao a tutta a tutte a tutti a tutto e a
tutto cerco di essere il più inclusivo
possibile adesso perché a causa
dell'argomento che andrò a trattare nei
prossimi minuti dovrò per Maggiore
aderenza essere il più possibile
esclusivo elitario e anche un po'
antipatico ma devo dire che mi riesce
abbastanza bene perché vi parlerò del
mondo dell'arte contemporanea e lo farò
aderentemente col grande tema delle
prospettive fornendovi il mio punto di
vista
sull'arte e il suo sistema Una
prospettiva che però non vuole per forza
dirsi innovativa Anzi secondo me molto
spesso dietro stare torica delle
prospettive innovative si cela la
rancida realtà della minestra riscaldata
venduta come nuova per cui senza fare
promesse o illusioni quella che Vi
propongo è sì dichiaratamente una
finestra riscaldata ma è la mia mi metto
riscaldata una prospettiva quindi
personale parziale sicuramente
discutibile che è quella di un giovane
artista italiano Eh sì come è stato
detto io tra le varie cose faccio
l'artista e notate bene che dico faccio
e non sono perché artista è una
categoria strana
pericolosa scivolosa a volte eroica
talvolta Patetica e presuntuosa artista
È una di quelle etichette un po' tipo
stronzo non è una cosa che ti puoi dire
da solo sono un artista è imbarazzante
per avere valore te lo devono dire gli
altri sei uno stronzo Il nostro sarà un
brevissimo viaggio dantesco in cui voi
siete i poeti sperduti nella selva
oscura della Biennale di Venezia e io il
vostro Virgilio meglio al Vigilio Direi
per l'occasione Qui non tanto per
guidarvi ma più a farvi perdere in
questa discesa tra le bolge e i gironi
della persona infernale del sistema
dell'arte senza possibilità di risalita
Tra l'altro perché scoprirete chi decide
di intraprendere una carriera nel mondo
dell'arte difficilmente riuscirà a
riveder le stelle al massimo le
confonderà con lo sbrilluccichio dei
lustrini e dei riflettori di questo
mondo fatto di rappresentazione finzione
e simulazione ma adesso incominciamo
Davvero è esattamente come nel viaggio
di Dante anche il portale d'ingresso al
mondo dell'arte presenta l'iscrizione
che disincentiva l'accesso soltanto che
io l'ho immaginato sul Guggenheim di New
York che tra l'altro proprio come forma
no ricorda l'imbuto che conduce a
Lucifero
ma proviamo a definire questo mondo
dell'arte de costruiamolo anzitutto
mondo o mondi al plurale
si usa anche sistema però le persone
preferiscono mondo in quanto più
rassicurante io lo trovo smielato E
dolciastro preferisco sistema in quanto
più diretto crudo quasi a dichiarare la
sua dimensione strutturale
dell'Arte è arte uno pensa subito a
pittura scultura video installazioni
performance in realtà secondo me arte ha
più a che fare con il linguaggio non ha
nulla di trascendentale o metafisico
arte un'etichetta che noi adagiamo
addosso le cose per descriverle come
opere d'arte
O meglio non lo facciamo proprio noi lo
fa una cerchia ristretta di addetti ai
lavori che ha il potere di sanzionare un
oggetto Come arte Per farla breve non è
che le cose stanno nei musei perché sono
arte semmai le cose sono arte in quanto
stanno nei musei vedete come sottile la
differenza per descrivere il mondo
dell'arte mi piace Poi servirmi della
formula di cornice sociale in quanto
secondo me molto più interessante
visualizzarlo non solo come un
contenitore di oggetti le opere di
luoghi musei fondazioni gallerie case
d'aste spazi indipendenti di eventi
fiere mostre biennali triennali
quadriennali oltremenali anali di ruoli
professioni artista curatore gallerista
collezionista giornalista critico
eccetera ma anche e soprattutto come
insieme di comportamenti
teorie convenzioni conformismi
stereotipi il mondo dell'Arte è il regno
dell'apparire delle informatività opaca
dei mercati sommersi è una struttura
perfettamente candidabile alle letture
più critiche contemporanee quali la
legittimazione dell'auto sfruttamento o
della servitù volontaria dell'economia
della presenza o della teoria
reputazionale Insomma capite perché per
me la vera opera è proprio il sistema
dell'arte
visualizzatelo come una corte medievale
diffusa con il Re Nudo che però è a suo
agio desnudo oppure come uno sfavillante
circo barnum e partiamo proprio
dall'ultima ruota di questo carrozzone
girovago l'artista spesso bistrattato in
realtà ricopre un ruolo fondamentale
all'interno del principale schema del
mondo dell'arte artista gallerista
collezionista l'artista falopera il
gallerista la vende Il collezionista la
compra e il cerchio si chiude tutto il
resto sta intorno
Secondo me gli artisti Oggi sono
soprattutto produttori di carriere la
vera opera non è tanto la singola opera
classicamente Intesa il dipinto La
scultura Il video installazione la
performance ma semmai l'insieme di
questo perette che va a comporre La
grande opera carriera è una meta
carriera
per utilizzare il registro linguistico
di Suzu l'arte della guerra le opere
classicamente intese stanno alla opera
carriera esattamente come le tattiche
stanno la strategia per cui gli artisti
realizzano queste opere tattiche che
Mirano a corrispondere al Grande Disegno
dell'Opera strategia dell'Opera carriera
e ciò spiegherebbe Come mai spesso la
firma valga più dell'Opera effettiva o
come mai consideriamo certi artisti alla
stregua di Superstar
Ma come si diventa artisti di successo
Perché poi di quello non si tratta della
ricerca del riconoscimento chi più chi
meno che sia quello internazionale o
quello da parte della mamma
Non conta quello che fai non conta
neanche quanta storia dell'arte tu
conosca fondamentale è la compresenza di
due fattori 1 genitori ricchi 2
conoscere le persone giuste vedete non
siamo poi così diversi dal resto del
pianeta anche se ci piace considerarci
una razza privilegiata perché la cosa
importante è stare e rimanere nel giro e
chi si estranea dalla lobby farà arte
Come hobby Ma chi sono questi personaggi
della corte a cui l'artista deve fare la
corte
Il curatore non è uno che ha studiato
Medicina non cura le persone ma cura le
mostre le esposizioni delle opere degli
artisti e anche qui non conta quello che
esponi per portare a casa il risultato
Bastano un buon comunicato stampa un po'
di Pubbliche Relazioni diffusione sui
media di settore un bellopening e la
vendita se c'è di mezzo la galleria
il comunicato stampa è un documento in
cui si presenta il progetto alla stampa
appunto al pubblico e ti scrive I
comunicati stampa è destinato Al Girone
infernale dei citazionisti ovvero dei
produttori sistematici di supercazzole
in quanto il loro sport preferito è
quello di cospargere I comunicati stampa
di citazioni da deluse
vediamo qui per contrappasso affogare
nei loro stessi abusi di citazioni
è gettare Fumo negli occhi no Per
colmare un vuoto contenutistico
allungare una minestra che come già
sapete è pure riscaldata Anche perché
se dopo aver letto il comunicato stampa
tu entri in galleria e in questo spazio
totalmente bianco Vedi per terra una
pallina di carta arrotolata con lo
scotch appoggiato al muro un rametto
secco Beh di delusiano c'è soltanto la
delusione Sicuramente
il gallerista non espone Galli in
galleria A meno che l'artista non abbia
previsto per la sua mostra di esporre
dei polli vivi cosa non così strana però
in effetti un po' il galletto il
gallerista lo deve fare perché deve
piazzare le opere degli Artisti ai
collezionisti quando vedete più gallerie
diverse in uno stesso luogo o vi trovate
sull'autostrada A7 in direzione Genova
oppure in una fiera d'arte Oppure ancora
alla Biennale di Venezia che è una fiera
travestita da mostra ma su questo
sorvoliamo per cui Come Dante anche noi
incontriamo le fiere che vengono
presentate all'interno di grandi
padiglioni con le gallerie che espongono
all'interno di stand quindi separate da
parete corridoi
esattamente da sembrare un labirinto per
topi la fiera Comunque è l'occasione per
vedere con un Colpo d'occhio le tendenze
del Mercato le principali gallerie con i
migliori artisti o meglio quelle che
possono permettersi l'affitto di uno
stand Comunque la fiera è il momento in
cui si materializza in carne ed ossa il
mercato dell'arte non è una novità che
si identifichi l'arte proprio con il suo
stesso mercato possiamo non essere
d'accordo con questa affermazione Però
sicuramente l'arte oggi non è soltanto
un importante ingranaggio dell'Industria
culturale
Secondo me l'arte oggi è anche e
soprattutto il centrotavola del
banchetto della società capitalista è un
po' Come darsi il deodorante senza prima
lavarsi le ascelle
Il collezionista è il vero protagonista
di questo carnevale dell'arte un po'
perché glielo si fa credere un po'
Perché in effetti Il carrozzone senza di
loro non girerebbe
comprano arte in cambio di status Symbol
o per investimento o per soddisfare un
particolare inquietante feticismo
Infatti L'arte è carta da parati Per
ricchi ma non solo oggi è probabilmente
lo è sempre stata Nella migliore delle
ipotesi è una buona decorazione da
abbinare con le tende della seconda casa
al mare
diversamente da quello che avete
imparato a scuola ovvero che non è bello
ciò che è bello ma è bello ciò che piace
Ecco nel mondo dell'arte contemporanea
Non è bello ciò che è bello ma è bello
ciò che costa e più costa più è bello
concludo parlandovi di critica d'arte e
pubblico cioè di voi che rappresentano
due modi diversi di incarnare
l'irrilevanza
il pubblico alla cerimonia dei valori
non è invitato mentre in altri settori è
proprio il pubblico a tenere le redini
della partita decretando il successo il
fallimento di un film di un libro di un
disco e con il mondo dell'arte
contemporanea al momento della
presentazione pubblica i giochi sono già
stati fatti e sono già stati fatti dal
vero pubblico dell'arte contemporanea
gli addetti ai lavori
attore e pubblico contemporaneamente
onanismo allo stato puro Anche perché
poi
all'artista per vivere basta non
gallerista e due o tre collezionisti e
fine ma anche la critica d'arte non è
invitata questa cerimonia dei valori
l'uomo folle miciano direbbe che la
critica d'arte è morta Beh proprio morte
Direi di no al massimo si è solo
trasformata in qualcosa di diverso
rispetto alla sua vocazione storica è
diventata
confermatrice del presente più che palla
da demolizione una tisanina
tranquillizzante un caffè decaffeinato
senza coraggio Eppure critica deriva dal
greco vuol dire separare discernere
saper distinguere il buono dal meno
buono e invece oggi la critica non ha
più bisogno di sapere e dirci cosa vale
perché per quello c'è già il mercato o
mi raccomando Nonostante tutto quello
che vi ho detto io il sistema dell'arte
ha anche dei difetti ma li vediamo la
prossima volta Grazie
[Applauso]